hi i'm eric boston adventures in games
time heist was so convoluted that even
the directors and the writers couldn't
agree on what the hell happens at the
end of the movie
why is cap's fate so damn confusing why
can't we just accept that he stayed in
the past to dance with peggy carter
until he turned into clint eastwood
because we are nerds and we overthink
everything and we know that anyone who
goes back in time and doesn't
immediately try to prevent 911 is
essentially complicit with al qaeda but
the more i've thought about this i've
realized that regardless of which
interpretation you apply to the final
scenes of avengers end game
the story of cap's alternate life is
super interesting
and definitely worth digging deeper into
and before i begin thank you to our
sponsor wix
wix allows you to build your own
professional website we actually use wix
to build an interactive website for you
guys to get more involved with us
more details later now i've already gone
into the details of what cap did in his
off-screen return trip
through time with the stones as well as
all the new branch universes created
through the time travel and end game go
check out those breakdowns if you
haven't already here let's look at cap's
endpoint and end game as an old man in
the year 2023 sitting by the lake
feeding ducks handing off his shield to
sam
wilson he says that he went to go get
that life tony was talking about
and that it was beautiful and when sam
sees his wedding ring he asks you want
to tell me about her and cap smiles and
says
no yeah i bet you don't want to talk
about it complicit
all we see of this beautiful life is the
final image of cap's slow dancing with
peggy carter in 1945 but
what else happened in cap's alternate
life according to the directors the
russo brothers cap stain in the past
created a new branch timeline
an alternate history that we never saw
ending with cap agent into an old man
and through some
mysterious technology or magic that old
cap hopped back to our main timeline to
say goodbye
hand off the shield to sam meanwhile the
screenwriters marcus and mcfeely said
that they had a different interpretation
that cap stain in the past just means he
stayed in this main timeline
aging into an old man in the background
of the history that we've already seen
and then showing back up when that
younger cap went back in time to close
this loop so let's first look at cap's
alternate life in the director's branch
history this version allows us to feel
better about cap
as a person because as far as we know
that alternate timeline extends to a
future that looks totally different
so imagine cap returns to the day his
younger self went down into the ice
february 5th 1945. he marries peggy
he gets in that raincheck dance and then
presumably cap's next move would be to
rescue bucky from hydra brainwashing in
siberia and for these next several years
in this alternate history
cap and bucky would probably be
operatives for shield a shield run by
peggy carter
cap would use his knowledge of 20th
century history to thwart the various
horrible events that happened
fighting hydro forces at every turn
since zola hinted that hydra was
manipulating world events through these
decades to destabilize the world with
terrorism hell if you think about it
hydra might even been behind 911.
and during this alternate hypothetical
history perhaps cap handed off the
shield to bucky allowing bucky to take
on the captain america name for a number
of years
because this version of bucky wouldn't
have been the winner soldier he'd be yet
another american hero
and that could explain why bucky was
bypassed for sam back in the main
timeline because in that reality sam
should get the turn now eventually
history for cap in this new timeline
would be changed so much that he
probably wouldn't be able to recognize
it or predict what would happen next so
he'd be able to just live out his life
normally
retiring peggy and their dozens of
perfect kids probably all them slow
dancing to that song because they're
weird i guess now the second
interpretation of the ending of this
film no
new branch just cap stays here that
violates the writer's own rules for time
travel in this movie major changes to
the past are supposed to create
new branches but they are saying that
the mcu history as we've seen it has
been secretly witnessed by an older
version of cap who did nothing to
intervene with it that we've been living
in a world in which cap returned in 1945
got with peggy abandoned pucky to get
brainwashed into an assassin who would
later murder tony stark's parents
and allowed hydra to corrupt world
governments for decades and decades
it also means that cap and peggy didn't
stay together
because we know from winter soldier that
peggy married another soldier and had a
family with him and steve was not
kissing his niece when he kissed sharon
carter
though it is possible that peggy's first
husband could have died and then maybe
she got back with steve
or she just spent her whole first
marriage emotionally cheating on her
husband with cap like don't tell me they
were just dancing
i suppose in game did reveal that peggy
kept a photo of steve rogers in her
office kind of a
thing to do to her husband actually some
have recently pointed out that one of
the pallbearers at paige carter's
funeral and civil war
kind of looks like old cap that would be
a sweet gesture old cap carrying one
side
young cap carrying the other though you
would think that young cap would
recognize an older version of himself
when they picked up the casket or set it
down
yeah wait are you hear me yeah let's see
together
now we should remember that cap would
probably have good reasons not to
interfere with historical events
remember in endgame stark
warned him that when you mess with time
and messes back and back in age of
ultron
he told stark
every time someone tries to win a war
before it starts innocent people die
every time reminder never to ask cap to
open a bag of chips so yeah it's
possible that cap was such a boy scout
that he stayed out of meddling with
world events leaving peacefully as a
civilian
even if it meant occasionally watching
an innocent people burn ultimately both
interpretations of the ending are
problematic cap living in an unseen
branch timeline makes it nonsensical
that he would switch back over to our
main timeline as an old man
and capstain in this timeline
contradicts everything we know about
peggy carter's life and kind of makes
them both trash but the most interesting
thing to me while re-watching this scene
is bucky's reaction while saying goodbye
to cap he seems to know that cap was
going to stay in the past and moments
later when cap reappears as an old man
bucky is not at all surprised he just
smiles and tells sam go ahead take my
legacy
sure it makes sense that bucky would
know his best friend's plans to stay
back in time with his long-lost love but
bucky
not at all shocked by the surreal image
of cap as an elderly man or just the
uncanny nature of time travel
yeah this could mean that bucky knew
this was gonna happen so let's go with
the version that
older cap stayed in this timeline
staying out of sight from younger cap
after he was thawed
after bucky showed back up and winter
soldier remember he went m.i.a for a few
years until civil war maybe during that
time
old cap made contact with bucky
apologizing for not rescuing him from
hydra but saying that he swore not to
meddle with formative events in history
and now he wants to secretly help bucky
stay on the run hidden from authorities
he helps him undo his hydra brainwashing
and he tells him that as much as he
would love bucky to carry the shield
bucky is just too much of a terrorist
figure so one day steve plans to give it
to
sam instead and bucky makes peace with
this now look if you really dig
cap's trip back in time reddit user suo
is still
i think charted out a super nerdy but
fairly airtight theory that cap going
back
actually creates a new identical branch
in the timeline that we're seeing
is just one of these infinite loops that
actually kind of reconciles the two
competing interpretations
but breaks your brain comment down below
with the life you think cap lived and
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos and subscribe to new rockstars for
more marvel thoughts and theories and
again
big thanks to our sponsor wix wix allows
you to build a professional website with
thousands of templates that
set you up with the site for whatever
you need it to be look if you want to
function as an adult in society you need
a legit place for people to find you
online with a platform that you control
and does what you needed to do
a blog a business a place to show off
your elaborate color-coded time travel
chart art
new rockstars actually used wix to build
our website go check it out
thanks to wix we have one place where
you have a direct line to us to give us
feedback and help us decide what kind of
videos to make next
all in a way that we can really hear it
doesn't get buried in tweets and
comments sections other places we
actually started using this feedback to
make special content like our
recent re-watch of the matrix so go on
that site and use it to help us decide
what movie to break down next when it
comes to design wix gives you infinite
possibilities to make your website your
own unique masterpiece
but wix takes care of all the heavy
lifting your site will be safe secure
you don't have to worry about all the
weird glitches like if you tried to
build the site by yourself as i've made
that mistake before and wix has a
solution for every need with features
like wix blog wix video
wix stores wix booking really anything
you need a website for to improve your
life
wix has you covered so build your own
website today by going to wix.com
go slash new rockstars or by using our
link in the description below
thank you for joining me and however cap
lived his alternate life it would be a
shame if he didn't at least spend a few
years as lumberjack because
damn our boy splits
[Music]
you